moderna inició los trámites para que los
entes reguladores de estados unidos y
europa aprueben su vacuna contra el
coronavirus es la segunda empresa
estadounidense en solicitar la
autorización de emergencia para
comercializar su vacuna contra el hobbit
19 y en su pleito anticipamos que el
beneficio de esta vacuna será bastante
significativo y realmente esperamos la
capacidad de implementar esto
inicialmente bajo la autorización de uso
de emergencia y walker en dos de los
30.000 voluntarios que participaron en
los ensayos 196 contrajeron la
enfermedad de los cuales 185 habían
recibido un placebo
del total solamente 30 personas
desarrollaron casos severos todos ellos
habían recibido un placebo con estos
resultados la compañía indica que el
fármaco ha demostrado una efectividad
del 94 1% para prevenir contagios y de
un 100% para prevenir casos severos
en términos de preocupaciones de
seguridad importantes amenazas serias a
nuestra salud no hemos visto ninguna
preocupación de este tipo hasta la fecha
sigue los pasos de facer y sus socios
alemanes bayón tec que solicitaron el 21
de noviembre la aprobación de emergencia
en eeuu también los reguladores
británicos evalúan la eficacia y
seguridad de las vacunas de astrazéneca
y the fighter se espera que de ser
aprobada la vacuna de moderna podría
comenzar a administrarse en eeuu a
partir del 21